you're mean one sheing
ping your heart no longer
feels you're a communist dictator with
tyrannical ideals J and
P You're an impressive desperate who
wants his tiny subjects to
kn
you're an Xin
ping your countries are
[Music]
shitole your media is full of liars who
do just what they told she
in I'd like to impel you with a 39 ft
bamboo
po you're a weak one Che in
ping you have noodles for a
spine you gave everybody Co from
experimental
trials given the choice between the two
of you I choose Co every
time you're a fascist shean
ping you're a king
without a
ground you hold down tiny people with
cameras all around
and the three words that best describe
you are as follows and I quote pork egg
[Music]
roll look everyone serves a master I
think that's important for us to
remember here around Christmas who are
you serving in your personal life that's
an answer that only you can give and one
that you can choose that's a story of
not only Christmas christ Redeeming the
world but Christmas Carol is like the
Fifth Gospel to me it's about a man
redeemed what kind of a god do we serve
if we don't believe the people can
change so if you think you need some
change in your life you can there's
someone in your life who you think won't
change they can pray for them you know
what right here at mug club we were uh
you know we were in a spot where we
definitely wanted some change and this
year was a year of a lot of
change they be Wes for a little bit
there are far more of us far more of you
than of them demand change demand better
we launched this year the re-platforming
initiative I've been
shadowbanned I've been silenced on
virtually every platform created by man
and that's why I'm joining mug Club
because of you we brought on Alex
Jones's show the Hodge twins Brian K Mr
guns and gears Nick
Apollo and because of you the Nashville
Manifesto happened that is entirely
because of you in the investigative unit
our source is fine we will go to jail to
protect our sources and because of you
we get to continue doing this program
without having to serve corporate
overlords that Constitution matters it's
not just a piece of parchment like those
values mean something I'm glad what
you're doing because instead of saying
media news it should say so the demons
said today everyone just might want to
hit a clean slate policy but do it so
that everyone can start using social
media to serve us and not serving this
algorithm nonhuman brain YouTube
Facebook they kept telling us what kind
of content we were permitted to post the
machine is what the root is all about
that is the Leviathan we got to stop
this because this is evil they're
starting at I'm superior to you that's
where they start their it big Tech does
not want this anywhere out there right
now no one no one can tell us what we
can't cover no one can tell us which
trails that we have to allow to run cold
this is the reason that mug Club exists
we didn't start this fight we don't want
it but if you want a fight you better
believe you've got one from the bottom I
think of everyone's heart here as a
thank you we cannot do this without you
we never would be able to and it's been
one hell of a year and we've enjoyed
every minute with this damn
crew so Alex Jones the Network
contributorship Rumble the
manifesto all of this is because of you
and uh we can't thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
enough
that's what I
know
I I know a strange
[Music]
animal Merry Christmas
oh oh I haven't heard that one before
that was that was
oh hello you're all that was why we were
laughing at an inside joke here a North
Pole joke with some of the elves and uh
you know what that's like there m cap
you're my captain elf yes indeed I help
out yes with speaking quite clearly no
not not not he's a man of few words I've
been busy with the elves getting all the
gifts ready and we have all these
wonderful people we're going to be
talking about he's a solemn elf it's
been fun a solitary elf he's a grumpy
elf I tell good jokes but I'm glad to be
with you this is this is the time of
year every year we've been doing this
now I don't know if it's been
uh four five years where we do this
Christmas episode as a thank you to you
mug Club none of this happens uh by the
way you know the mug Club is the reason
they have me Santa on retainer mhm it's
not cheap Santa no it's not I don't show
up for just anybody yeah especially the
week before Christmas you're a very bus
true very very busy man I mean you know
there's the rule of delegating if the
elves can do it 70% as effective as you
your delegate I'm still looking for an
elf who can it's the time so I just get
more elves you just throw more elves at
it and eventually you know it's a
self-solving problem it does so we thank
you so much this is the time of year
where we give back of course you can
sign up uh through the end of the year
you'll get this this book Santa's a fan
of it the beautiful differences
children's book to read to your children
because that's really what's most
important this time of year is spending
time with your family spending time with
those you love time with those who maybe
need a little bit of help and that's the
theme here this year we've worked with
the One Tribe Foundation which Works
hand inand with with veterans with First
Responders people who've served this
country and uh you know maybe come on
some tougher times or maybe just need a
little bit of help every now and then
and they've really helped us to find
some families uh you've submitted some
we've worked hand inand with them to see
where we can do the most good and it's
nice you know just to cut through the
fog at the end of the year and
absolutely be able to just spend some
time giving back and not dealing with
politics or culture or social media
frankly I'm not thrilled that I have
this iPad in front of me well it's
necessary did we make this we didn't no
that was oh we imported no that's
assembled by one of those uh on the
naughty list this government the entire
country mostly so we thank the One Tribe
Foundation you can look into them and
see how you can help people in your neck
of the woods and we'll be talking with
several families this year hopefully
making their Christmases very special
which is only made possible through you
viewers like you mug club and of course
Santa on retainer so let's first see a
very special
family the Carell
family how you doing my name is uh
Michael Carell I was a United States
Marine from 1998 to
2007 deployed with the third uh third
Marine exp force in 2004 to Iraq
[Music]
and you know since then afterwards I I
got out and I started working in in real
estate started doing pretty good but um
uh unfortunately in January 2021 I was
diagnosed with a stage
4B uh colon cancer that has spread
through my liver it has uh continued to
spread since that time frame to my lymph
nodes my lungs and my stomach wall but
we keep grinding and uh keep living life
every single day to the fullest and try
to enjoy it as much as we can
I am married to a beautiful woman named
Gabriella who is uh with me and we have
three beautiful children Liam natala and
Alexa who are 15 13 and 9 Going on
30 that's a that's about it about
me and we really appreciate the One
Tribe Foundation helping us uh put us in
touch with the family Michael Carell a
veteran who served this country a true
hero I just give out a few toys every
now and then I mean you know I'm a fan
of it but what this man has done really
uh makes makes what we do here at the
North Pole P pale in comparison and this
man has had a rough go he's had to
endure around 130 plus rounds of chemo
treatment mhm with his family I'm sure
that there are times where you know he's
he really um it's very precious how much
time he has left and we want to make
that time a little more special this
time of year so we have them I believe
on the line This is is new fangled
technology I'm really a welding and
woodworking man but you know they they
briefed me let's go uh right now to
spend some time and make the day a
little more special with the Carnell
family can you all see Santa is that the
Carnell family yeah yes oh oh it is
Merry Christmas you're all there aren't
you yes sir Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas to okay so let
me see if I have this right I'm going
from my right your left to your left my
right I don't know sen I have elves who
take care of that for me with north
south we have Dad we have Michael we
have
Gabriella and then oh right there with
with Mickey I think I see is is that
little
Alexa little Alexa oh and then right
next to you is uh Natalia and then Big
Brother Liam do I have that right yeah
yes yeah oh the whole brood is there
that's that's wonderful oh I can see
that oh Alexa's pretty excited does is
that uh is that a special uh special
stuffed plush toy for you there that
Mickey yeah
yeah do you do you take it with you uh
when you go to sleep do you take it with
you all the places you go or is that
just you wanted to show it off here for
Santa I bring it everywhere you bring it
everywhere
wow well you know Santa has uh here at
the North Pole we have some old stuffed
toys you can't see but we have an old
stuffed reindeer that's that's more
Taxidermy so I can't take it everywhere
with me but I I know how important it is
you take care of that now Alexa okay
I'll go through everyone here one by one
uh
you're nine this year do I have that
correct yeah okay and I I think that Dad
there says you're you're nine but going
on 30 you're you're pretty you're an old
soul I
hear
yeah sure Mr what do you mean by that
when you say that uh Michael she's an
old soul just she just nine but just you
know acts way older than she really is
so well hopefully in a good way you mean
she's helpful and responsible and not
that she has creaky hips yeah for the
most part sometimes Maniac but you know
for the most part pretty good oh well
that's what's fun about children you
know brings a real smile to Santa's
faces even when they're Maniacs usually
they're trying to do the right thing so
Alexa do uh are you still uh still very
into to
soccer yeah okay now tell me you I think
I know but s we don't play a lot of
soccer here at the North Pole it's more
of a hockey town we have yet to get a
professional team but I do follow soccer
because it's International Santa's
favorite players is
Messi who's
yours Messi oh oh oh look at that what a
coincidence what is it you like about
him that he's a good soccer player what
a coincidence that's why Santa likes
him he's a sure bet in which I don't
take part but I mean figurative
figuratively now are you uh are you
helping are you helping Gabriella and
helping dad you're helping your family
all year round have you been a good
girl yeah yeah what kind of things does
she do there uh dad around the
house uh she likes to do the dishes
actually oh she likes doing dishes is
that true
Alexa yeah well that's a valuable skill
set there'll always need to be dishes
that need
doing and then right next you we have n
Natalia you're you're 13 this year
correct correct yeah and you it seems
like it's a big soccer family you you
actually you're a striker for for solar
soccer club right yes and did you have
one of your one of your games it was out
there on television for everyone to
see yeah yeah which which game was
that in
Orlando Oh in or is that a big soccer
town I don't know
well I thought was more of a basketball
spot but I know that soccer's you know
it's spreading everywhere now now you
have brother Liam oh look at that look
at that giant head of hair Liam when's
the last
time when's the last time you had that
Mars Volta main
trimmed Jude
June June do you mean June of this
year yeah I cut it all off on June so
this was down to you cut it all off you
mean down to like a full GI Jane
yeah and it just grew back like
that wow well tell you what Santa is
envious of those times I haven't had a
hair head of hair like that for geez at
least 140 years it's still there I'll
take it but not that
thick and you're uh if I understand
right Liam you're you're learning uh
some valuable skills in school right
what what is it you're doing right
now uh I'm in welding right now oh where
welding well welding you know there's a
shortage of welders right now and that's
an important trade is that something you
plan on doing later in life yeah kind of
what does that mean kind of that doesn't
sound so sure as W you're back up
skateboarding go to the X
Games yeah I don't I don't really know
yet it's like
50/50 all right well it's still a good
skill you'll keep with you nonetheless
and we have some Elves here it's you
know employment retention is hard in
this economy and some Elves they went
off and some of them are welding in
Orlando woodworking too so everyone
needs them out there I'd certainly
consider it now let me ask you Alexa
Natalia and Liam what is it that you
want for Christmas this year
Mickey you you Alexa do you mean you
want a a bigger
Mickey yeah how big show me show me how
big because I I can only I can see you
you're right oh oh oh oh that's a that's
a big Mickey that's almost something
you'd only see in Orlando at the theme
park I don't know if there's one that
big that can fit down the chimney what
do you think Ma what do you think
they're Michael in in Gabriella I don't
know it might be a hard one to fit down
the chimney yeah that's for sure it
might be hard but there are ways now
where they do you know like mattresses
in a box they shrink wrap it there are
ways to make it happen I believe but
only if you're a good girl Alexa and and
your brother and sister they're older so
they'll tell us the truth has has Alexa
been a good girl this year
sometimes
uhoh uhoh well what does that mean you
have to share share
like um sometimes I don't know I don't
know all right well you know listen
that's also hey Alexa I understand she's
your sister so there's a little bit of
sibling rivalry I might not be getting
the full accurate report really it
matters what Michael and Gabriella say
what what say you she's been good she's
been really good very good yes have all
of them been
good yes yeah for the most part do all
of you help out help out your dad there
and make sure he has everything he
needs you sure do well that's that's
important do you you do you know how
much your dad has done for this
country you know that right you know
that Santa look I'm I'm very grateful to
be able to do what I do at the North
pole that brings a smile to my face but
I wouldn't be able to do it if there
weren't people like Michael out there
fighting for the country and making sure
that all people people and elves alike
can be free you're aware that you're
that that Michael's an actual hero
right yeah I want to go that far but oh
don't be bashful I'm the one who has the
pink Rosy
Cheeks everyone here deserves to know
what it is that you've done and taken
care of all these people with everything
that's been happening the last few years
I I understand you know I have a family
of my own and it can be tough especially
really the last year since 2020 it's
been tough for a lot of people and look
if everyone is good I think that you'll
have a good Christmas this year if you
keep helping you keep helping dad you
keep helping Gabrielle you make sure
their life is easier but we do every now
and then we have a VIP list where I
don't know if you know this sometimes
Santa gives you some gifts early did did
you know that no did I know that
Li Liam Alexa did you know that that's
that those are the
rules it's actually in the contract
there's a certain percentage of families
who've gone above and beyond who I'm I'm
legally bound to provide them with some
gifts early does that sound like you do
you want it to be
you all right well we have a couple of
things here for your family this year I
know that you're all big soccer family
it seems and so right here so you can do
it all as a family because there's
nothing more important we have season
tickets for the whole family the FC
Dallas and you can go as watch as many
soccer games as you want to your heart's
content how does that sound wow what do
you say you that's awesome thank you so
much Santa and I know it's no giant it's
no giant Mickey Alexa yet but that's
still something that'll be fun you can
do with your and I'm pretty sure you can
bring your Mickey with you right if if
Gabriella and and and and the old man
there say it's okay I think you can
bring Mickey but don't lose it now yeah
can't lose
Mickey Micky anyway all right well we
don't have we don't have a giant Mickey
here today but we do have something else
that's rather big and actually my elf is
going to bring this in this is for the
whole family right now we have a big
check for you because your story touched
us so much here at the North Pole
for the entire Cardel family for
$30,000 so you can help the whole family
have a great Christmas this year and
ease things a little
bit there
you thank you oh Michael thank you thank
you Santa for everything you've
done we really do appreciate it here at
the North Pole a lot of people sometimes
I know it's just lip service but you
know I've had some family members who've
gone through similar things and if we
have the ability to reach out and help
someone boy I can't think of a better
brood and so look we're going to be
presenting to you guys some more gifts
uh I think we'll do it though can you
all wait until
Christmas yes oh Alexa Alexa I couldn't
see I was I was looking at your father
she's crying I hope those or tears of I
didn't know that that you understood the
currency exchange at your
age that was really more for Michael and
Gabriella so that you know you can help
them all have a great Christmas but I
think she knows that you're on the hook
for an extra large
Mickey we do a lot of things together so
we learn together well that's the most
important thing and I hope that this
helps your family this year but really
as long as you have each other there's
nothing that Santa can bring bring down
that chimney that's going to mean
anything more than that it's not even
close no right and Michael Gabriel is
there anything that any of you were
going to be going here now and I'll see
you soon Christmas Eve if you're all
very good and by the way Alexa Natalia
Liam you I I have a direct report from
the people who are head of household
there is there anything you'd like to to
say to folks out there Christmas or any
questions you have for Santa I maybe
Alexa you have questions about how all
of this works I usually do get them
any questions her she's
thinking well that's a value that's a
valuable mindset as opposed to just
reacting that's when you make
mistakes sometimes you know you get a
few eggnogs and Santa we're shooting the
breeze with the elves that's not when we
plan our yearly calendar I tell you that
oh man well thank you I know look we
have to go here it's a very busy time of
year and and uh Michael Gabriel I know
we've spoken with you we have uh more
that will be coming your way and of
course for all the children there at
Christmas but you have to open it at
Christmas and be good until then and
please can you all do me a favor promise
Santa here that you're going to take
care of that man there and that woman
because they've taken such good care of
you I need to hear it I need to hear I
promise promise oh and that is legally
binding under penalty of perjury
thank you so much to the Carnell family
we hope you have a Merry Christmas and
we'll be seeing you soon thank you so
much we can't say thank you enough thank
you oh you've done more than enough this
is a small repayment I assure you with a
great deal many back payments in there
as well thank you very much Michael we
here can't thank you enough and your
story is one that I know will inspire uh
many people not just across the North
Pole but certainly the country that
you've helped defend we really can't
thank you enough we appreciate it
thank you Merry Christmas to the whole
family I'll see you
soon bye now bye little Mickey I think
you might have a big brother soon bye
Carnell family oh well that was nice
absolutely love giving that the the
people who have served our country
something Santa that's fantastic to do
some a check to help out a lot of kid
like toys we don't want to tell them the
toys but we know obviously we've packed
well yes I know they're off of their
list I didn't just pack them I built
them you well that's true true too so
well I mean elves helped I mean that's
kind of our job and then you over oh
they get all the credit you they do
that's that's look the signature items
you think a PS5 just happens no no
that's a lot of work no no of course lot
of a lot of request this year for
standup standup paddle boards the hands
are too small they can't do it yeah
that's
true and I'm not a big fan of it either
look we don't have a lot of surfing at
the North Pole you know we have to have
you con itch out some areas and it's
really just sort of chop it's not
they're not rolling waves but I don't
get it standup paddle board you're not
surfing you're not kaying you're moving
very slowly but I hear it's a great Core
workout so we'll have some more that we
be coming to I believe we'll be talking
with the uh the foundation yes whove
helped make all of this happen who've by
the way helped make all this happen with
your support out there through the North
Pole and mug club we appreciate it we do
this every year and we can't do it
without you we can't help these families
or bless them without your help and
there are a lot of people involved
behind the scenes not just building toys
but all year long to make this happen
and I believe we have some more
Christmas greetings from some of our
best friends let's go to them
[Music]
now season greetings mug Club season's
greetings to mug Club hello everybody
let's make this Christmas holiday the
best one yet huh what do I want for
Christmas let's see what do I want for
Santa for Christmas this year I'm asking
Santa
for peace I want a better chest not
peace on Earth I mean that's a major
thing it'd be great but I'm actually
just ask for peace in my household the
kind of chest looks good in silk shirts
make CNN publish and release to their
viewership the recently released j6
videos on a muscar chest and make sure
that paramedics are standing by for the
shock that that will have to their
viewers who have been lied to for a long
time just give me a little bit of piece
the kind of chest that carries a a cross
a chain with a cross or maybe even a
Greek horn beautifully speaking of that
what I love about Steven Crowder is he
stood up for free speech before it was
popular my favorite memory of Steven
well we would call it like in a Hallmark
movie we'd call it a meat cute we were
on a
catamaran out in the SE shells I was in
Detroit Michigan I was boarding a plane
we were fishing I was teaching him how
to fish he's uneasy on a boat he he
uneasy in nature headed I don't know
where I was going but leaving Detroit of
course I am at one with nature and there
was this really handsome guy I bumped
into whoops excuse me got a little
emotional there and I remember we caught
a wind and I had to tie him to the Mast
and he said hi my name is
Steven and I recognized him already I
knew who he was and some Orca some orc
came up and they uh began to swim
alongside us that was it it was a
magical moment anyway still my favorite
moment with Stephen merry Christmas
everybody Merry Christmas Jesus
greetings Merry Christmas
especially to The Mug club
[Music]
members
well that was that's one down yes one
down I love the holiday and I don't mean
down what I mean is look you don't think
that's you don't think Santa gets a
little Misty eyed oh I know I've got to
keep it together kid keep it
together and here's the thing Heroes
come in all shapes and sizes I have a
handle on it now good you got it it's
your job Chris cringle it's your
job uh this next one he's a 10-year-old
boy yeah 10-year-old boy and I'm not
throwing the term hero around
willy-nilly because he did a tick tock
dance right uh this boy Chandler Gibson
he actually saved a classmate's life
really saved a classmate's life by using
the heick maneuver one of his fellow
students was choking and he stepped in
which really can teach us all a little
bit here certainly as we go into the
Christmas season sometimes Heroes appear
in the most unlikeliest of forms shapes
ages and you know what there's no reason
that an any given day that hero can't be
you and this young man actually appeared
in a local news who was pretty excited
about it I believe we have the story
right here let's go to this story about
young Mr Chandler Gibson hero we are
meeting a decator Elementary student who
jumped into action when his classmate
started choking saving his friend's life
just hit you right here 11 lives Britney
Klein Peter got to sit down with that
fifth grader to hear his story it was
just your average school day when
Chandler Gibson says he saw his
classmate choking on an Apple he tells
me he didn't even hesitate to help what
do you want to be when you grow up I'm
going to be an NFL player an NFL player
yes he believed he could so he did that
inspirational quote describes this
10-year-old perfectly and when he is
interested in things he goes all in and
he as he proved with something like this
my friend start choking right here so I
got up then helped him Chandler says it
was just days earlier when he came
across a heck tutorial video I usually
watch YouTube like that and it popped up
to think I see appear
choking I'm going to remain
calm utilize what I've learned online to
save their life yes he really is a true
superhero a superhero with without a cap
now you are a leader in the school but
with what some would call the superpower
of having faith in himself it makes me
feel like you know the by parenting
having gone in vain you know
big with an attitude that more of us
could learn from anything else you
wanted to say and I want to
say I I hope you have a great
weekend and here's the thing doing the
right thing sometimes it's contagious it
just takes one person to start exactly
and it has this Chain Reaction so
channelers heroics actually they
inspired the school staff to train all
of their students and staff uh on how to
perform the HCK maneuver because they
know that it could save a lot of lives
which frankly when I was
younger back in the 1700s was kind of
standard procedure yeah having the the
he I was a little alarmed that it it had
fallen out of
favor oh thank goodness for videos the
point is you know everything changes but
the and butter the basics are things you
should always know including the heck
and have a first aid kit on hand at all
times because we can't all have a young
Chandler let's go to him now and his
mother
Jennifer okay oh all right can everyone
there can you see and hear
Santa yes okay so that's I want to make
sure I'm looking at a small scanta you
know my eyes aren't what they used to be
so as we do this here with the new
technology and zoom and time facing that
looks like Jennifer and is that is that
oh is that Chandler
Gibson yes Chandler
Gibson I've heard a lot about you how
are you doing my
boy doing good yeah did you did you have
a good a good year this
year yes want to tell us a little bit
about you I hear that you you you had
some uh some pretty big events you were
on a local news story for helping out
one of your fellow
students yes what what what happened
Chandler because it's important for
everyone to hear that your story can
inspire a lot of people to do good work
and and help other folks at their
schools okay so what happened was I
learned this stuff on YouTube my friend
start choking on an Apple so I jumped in
action so I did a home lick I'm lick man
H lick manure mhm that's okay it's a
tough word even for Santa it's an old
Germanic word
heick sounds sounds aggressive but it's
actually to help save now Chandler where
did you learn to do the
hylick I like I learned it on YouTube
shorts I watch YouTube a lot and stuff
so I learned it and you just knew right
away when you saw someone you saw a
fellow student choking you knew to to
jump into action when did you make that
decision because a lot of people would
sit there and they get scared and not do
anything yeah so I was how do I make
that decision was I was thinking so I
I'm remember to jump in action and save
his
life
that's pass out that's incred and he he
ended up being okay Chandler right yes
now do you think that uh maybe some more
students there at your school will be
doing the same thing next time they see
someone doing that
yes definitely well I hope they follow
your example you know that's one thing
that Santa's always tried to to tell
people you know a lot of people get tied
up with the gifts and the coal and the
reindeer that's a lot of fun but really
what Santa's trying to do is set an
example where you help people with no
expectation of something in return just
because it's the right thing to
do yes and I appreciate that now I know
that uh also Jennifer you'll tell me mom
is has he been a good outside of the
heroic say he been a good boy this
year yes Chandler is a very helpful big
brother he's he's not only is he a hero
to the world but he's a hero here with
our family as well he's a big help and
he's he definitely does what he's
supposed to do I couldn't be any prouder
than I am so that's that's fantastic and
what kind of things do you do Chandler
to help Mom around the house with
brother
I make sure my brother stay in check and
do not mess with the room cuz I do not
want my mama have a stress day I want I
want her to have a great
day he keeps him in check oh that's
that's Wonder does he do that Jennifer
he keeps him in check he does he does he
keeps them on top of things definitely
and Chandler do you help around the the
house do you help with chores and
cleaning up yes well that's a good thing
to do not only for your mom but you know
it's good for you because if I remember
correctly you're still very into
football you is the the Atlanta Falcons
are they still your number one
team yes okay and so one day you'd like
to play
football yes well you know for for the
Falcons what if what if you you know
what's your your your safety the
Cowboys not the
Lions no no what's your back my backup
team is the Ravens the Ravens okay all
right y because you know the the Lions
they they pretty much get coal every
year yes the Ravens they got good
players especially lar Jackson like one
of my favorite quarterbacks in the NFL
right now okay well you know the good
thing about doing chores is you know
Santa's a lot bigger than people realize
and uh never once seen the gym it's all
from a of manual labor feeding the
reindeer I have to move hay bales and
and that have you heard of the term
farmer
strength yes that's just if you do those
things you help your mom you know help
if she needs you to clean the floors or
even dishes that'll help you get strong
and help you become a better athlete
increase those chances of of playing
football yes well I hope to see you one
day out there in the field takes lots of
lots of practice and and what about uh
what about basketball though is that
something that maybe you're entertaining
too yes I play basketball a lot like I
go we got a basketball like go or
breakyard oh I go
back and stuff but you'd rather play
football if you had your choice
professionally yes well how does mom
feel about that because there's a lot of
talk even here at the North Pole you
know we do have it used to be a full
contact elf uh football league but the
conversation of CTE has arisen so
Jennifer do you have a preference of
football or
basketball I prefer I would prefer
basketball but he's definitely more into
football um I just try to stay positive
and hope for the best because it is a
very physical sport um his little
brother plays football as well um but
he's on a different team and they travel
and things like that so Chandler you
know he he sees that so he he's um he
it's it's really what he enjoy to doing
you know so I just try to stay positive
and just hope that he doesn't you know
get hurt because it's very physical
that's right well it's a very oh I see
chadler sinking his head you is that you
saying Mom I'll be
fine yes look she worries about you
because your mother loves you very very
much she actually reached out Direct L
didn't just send a letter she called my
direct line for Santa said look my son's
been very good I want you to hear his
story and he's a very unique boy so she
loves you a lot so it's very important
that you listen to her and if you you do
a lot of sports you have to make sure
you recharge and eat food stay healthy
so you know you can do that with Foods
you like it could be I know you love
fish and crab and and your mom actually
says and this is special that she
doesn't have any trouble making you eat
your vegetables you do that all on your
your own yes two days ago I think it's
like one day or two days
ago she made some crab legs with a salad
and I ate all my
salad M that sounds that sounds
delicious mom do you think maybe this
year I I get a little I appreciate it
but I get a little tired of milk and
cookies some crab legs left out don't
sound half bad do you think you could
maybe make that happen we make him pull
that off Santa okay oh fantastic I we
don't we don't get as you'd think
Alaskan king crab we'd have it at the
North Pole but it's a whole migration
thing the El Nino effect so we don't
have a lot of it and I know you love
your vegetables uh uh Gibson and you
also though it's important to train your
mind not just your body as you get older
right and education is important and are
you still really pretty I hear you're
pretty good at math is that still the
case yes what what part of math is your
favorite would you say
um I like to do like times
multiplication yeah
multiplication and and and minus and
pluses okay you do your addition
subtraction do you do long division
yet yes oh that's that's that could be a
little bit tough can't
it yes yeah s Santa doesn't I it's been
so long since I've done long division I
don't know if I remember last time I did
it was I believe
in
1864 so you know my memory is not
exactly what it used to be we live a
long time I have elves who do it for me
now Gibson is it uh is it still what you
want this year I know you have a few
things that you want for Christmas but
uh what is it what is it that uh you you
really want for
Christmas I only want a PS5 you want to
P well here's the thing you know um ps5s
I'm sure you've heard have been in
little bit of a shortage this year yes
so they hard I'm sorry what was that if
I like like if I can't get a PS5
recommend it is like to get like if I
can't get a PS5 I rather to like get
like something like some shoes and stuff
okay so you so you you don't have to get
a PS5 you'd be grateful for anything you
get but you you'd really like
one yes well there's a shortage but the
good news is and let's hit those clay
Bells here at the North Pole we have an
inside Lane and if you've been very good
I can tell you about a gift early this
year this actually by request from your
mother I can promise you if you eat all
your crab legs and vegetables and do
your long division that you will in fact
get a PS5 for Christmas how does that
sound yes yes that's this is you know
they're hard to come by it this is
almost it's better than gold
yes so look I'm going to but you know
you don't get to open it until Christmas
but we have this here for you I'm going
to put it down right here and make sure
that we keep the oh it's heavy yes that
means it's
expensive
yes thank you thank you no ABS it is my
pleasure and just so you know of course
there'll be more presents going over
there to your household for you and and
and Mommy um and we have some some
things for Mom too because seems to me
that Mom's done a pretty good job with
you and and she deserves to get some
nice things for Christmas wouldn't you
say yes all right what would you most
what do you think your mom deserves most
for
Christmas she deserves um
love
and she deserve like love and how much
she like she spend money all us and and
work hard I think she need like
something for Christmas but I don't know
like what she like
well you know that's a conversation that
Santa and Mom can have but I tell you
what of course we all love you here at
the North Pole and your mother but the
most important person do you know who
the most important person is to give
your mom
love what that's got to be that's got to
be you give give your mom a big hug for
us right so we can all see show your mom
how much you love her she put all this
together oh look
oh look at that oh that just warms
Santa's heart that's why we do all of
the but make sure you do that all year
round because your mom has a very tough
job but she seems to be doing pretty
well and you of course if you see anyone
else you know choking uh you know don't
be shy to use that
heick yes okay is there anything else
that you you'd like to ask Santa or say
to anyone at the North Pole before we
let you go here this
Christmas um have a great day and have a
great Christmas thank you and thank you
for having me being on the show well no
thank thank you so much for doing what
you do being a great son to your mother
and classmate to all of your friends at
school and please keep doing that and
Mom keep doing a great job and you do
that you'll get more presents at
Christmas and this PS5 will be there for
you before you know it okay thank you so
much thank you Jennifer and thank you
Chandler I appreciate it so much you all
have a very merry Christmas and I'll see
you
soon okay thank you bye byebye now oh oh
oh oh oh that just warms your heart
doesn't it elf elf Gerald it does yeah
gave the the the the heick maneuver was
fantastic A
PS5 mom gets some gifts out of it as
well it's great it's true and he is you
know what is a new thing what he has two
last two last names Chandler Gibson
Chandler Gibson Mr Gibson they said well
you did the football reference you
called him Gibson that's what they call
him on the football field that's what
they'll call him on the football field
you have to use that's what he'll have
on his Jersey yeah hopefully not the
Lions no that's a terrible te they are
awful Santa loves everybody but they're
testing my patience let's go before we
go to our next guest uh I believe we
have another holiday greeting here for
us at the North Pole which is a surprise
to Santa you put me on the spot here but
all right let's take a
look hey Merry Christmas mug Club Merry
Christmas to all of you Merry Christmas
mug Club season greetings to The Mug
Club season greetings the great folks in
mug Club you know this year I'm asking
Santa Claus for matching
socks all the same they got to fit but
they they've got to match this Christmas
I will be asking really just for the
phone number of Nancy Pelosi's stock
broker health is what I'm asking God for
this year Santa not so much I'm asking
for world peace and that we stop World
War II this Christmas that's my wish
you're doing a good thing support Steve
you know he's a real Warrior for the
parallel economy and Free Speech my
favorite memory of Steven Crowder is
when Rumble launched we did a live
stream together on my YouTube channel
and in the first 15 or 20 seconds stepen
violated about 15 YouTube Community
guidelines and I was thinking wow this
guy's really close to the hey this is on
my channel my favorite memory of stepen
is when I come marching up you didn't
know was coming Austin a few years ago
and just say I'm going to attack you I'm
going to get you and he knew it was a
joke so stevenh gets a good joke I love
Steven Crowder it's great to be a guest
in the show too and talk to you guys you
guys are great Merry Christmas
everyone cool late Taste of Freedom
[Music]
though I'm a little parched oh Santa
yeah you know Captain can you help me I
just have to have a little would be hon
sip of yes absolutely so our next fan
seltzer water seltzer water that clear's
the pallet it does it there's some
bubblies in there so be careful so the
next family is the gilray family with
Katie gilray uh and her three sons
Camden gunar and Braden and Katie's
husband Marine Corps staff sergeant
Donnie gilray III died suddenly in 2020
um and since that tragic loss Katie has
been working tirelessly commuting to
work 3 hours um two and from work to
ensure that she would be able to keep uh
her and and Sergeant gilr's dream of
raising their family in beautiful Texas
and uh and keep everything going for
that family she really has had to do a
lot and have it on her
shoulders of course you know sometimes
children don't fully grasp the uh I
guess I should say the long-term impact
of that but I'm sure they're living it
dayto day and we definitely know that
Katie has and I would imagine has been
probably spread a little thin yes which
really spoke to us here and boy does she
love her her family uh and we're happy
to be able to help her hopefully this
Christmas season absolutely I mean we
hope there's only so much we can do
right absolutely you know things like
love or health can't bring that down a
chimney or through a keyhole yeah but
helping out we can help them out a
little bit here is actually the
submission I believe we have from the
gilray family hi I'm Katie gilray I am
the wife of Donnie gilray III uh Donnie
served the United States Marine Corps
for over 14 years not only as a marine
but as an athlete he played for the
football team and uh he left us on March
7th
2020 and together we have three
incredible children we have bradden
who's 13 Gunner who seven and Camden
who's just turned six we live in
Farmersville Texas
and we miss Donnie every day and uh we
struggle at Christmas because we miss
his present so much
we miss his smile and his laugh and just
all the family traditions we used to
do hey
Bubba D home I would just say it gets
really hard around Christmas being a
soul parent and being everything to
everyone and spreading my time uh to my
kids and making sure everything gets
done it just gets extremely difficult
and also I just feel like everything
fails around Christmas and the holidays
like vehicles and something in the house
is just always something just always
goes wrong and it's usually
true uh I just want to thank you for
caring enough to hear about us and our
stories I'm glad to send a longer video
or talk more and let you know more about
the boys and I and Donnie's story
because Donnie's pretty incredible and
he's worthy to have his legacy live on
and that's our goal thank
you
[Music]
oh so I believe actually now uh we have
her and her family on the line tool man
elf you have everything queued up sure
do okay you know because that's I've
delegated that to you 70%
now let's go now to the gilray
family oh I'm seeing this right now
we're bringing up the picture here oh oh
oh oh is that the gilray family I
see y yes hi Santa Hi how are you doing
great good are you all having a Merry
Christmas this this year thus
far yep so far great let me look here
and make sure I have this right I know
the oldest there that's that's Braden
that's Mama Katie and then I'm looking
at a small screen sorry we have all this
technology at the North Pole that's
Gunner and Camden right are you you're
still you're six and seven years
old yes know
that is that is that Gunner playing
marionette with Camden's
hand yeah got lots of for you today
Santa you're treating him like a little
vendil elf C can you do that again
Gunner yeah oh come on Santa needs a
laugh just what what you were doing with
his arm there you
go oh we could put some some little
paint in his hand it could be like a
little uh albino senior
wies so all right Katie I know now you
boys your your mom reached out directly
to Santa this year uh and said that
you've been all been very good boys is
that is that that
true for the most part oh for the most
part well what do you mean Braden what
what kind of issues could we be running
into I know I've been good but I can't
say the same for gunar and camon uh oh
Gunner would you say that you've been a
good boy this
year yeah yeah what what kind of things
have you done that that's been good you
help out your mom
there I'm the only one to listen to her
it's true what what was that I didn't I
didn't fully hear what he said what you
said there I'm only one who listen to
her really oh and the plot thickens
Braden
no no that is not true and what about
what about Camden Camden have you been a
good boy this
year
yeah well really the only opinion that
matters here because the the tiebreaker
is is Mama Katie Katie what what do you
say is is is uh is gunar the only one
who
listens gunar is a really good listener
but I couldn't do it without Braden he's
always so helpful at everything and
Camden just brings so much joy and uh
drama to our lives I don't think we
would live full I only draw I only draw
only they're all three wonderful yes
well that's F okay well let me go
through this here so so Camden are you
still really do you still uh still very
into slime do you do you pick it up if
you play with
it what yeah yeah you do he tries to
make it oh but it not he tries to make
slime about no glue yes which is it ends
up in the fridge and gets messy
everywhere yeah oh well look there was a
very popular item with slime back in the
'90s they called it gak and uh found out
that it was a gross violation of safety
and health hazards so they had to change
the for formula but if you make it at
home you should be fine C Camden do you
still like what do you like do you like
building things and taking them apart if
I remember correctly you you're like
working with your
hands my hands work but you always take
things apart Knows What You Do obviously
because he sees you dismantling a lot of
your
toys well that's okay if if they're toys
that that are meant to be dismantled and
and sometimes do you have do you still
uh you still play baseball a lot there
Camden no he doesn't you don't have to
answer I play t-all well t-ball that's
like training wheels for baseball that's
how we all
start I play football a lot that's
because we like to play football he
likes football now yeah okay play
football he joins us so we've moved from
a non- contct sport into full-fledged
football but at your age they don't do
they stay they play tackle or is it old
touch
football no no you don't play tackle he
hasn't played football for a team yet he
he he if he plays football he has to
play flag they all want want me to be
number four
teammate they want they want you to be
number
14 the four Oh I thought there was
something special about that that number
well and then and then Gunner you really
I know that you're very into football if
remember the Cowboys still your number
one
team yeah yeah who's who's your favorite
player there on the Dallas
Cowboys C CD lamb okay all right well if
I remember correctly he's been on my
good list this year so uh you know not
so much with the 49ers it depends from
year to year it's touch and go it's
touch want 49 I know he likes the 49ers
but you know they they they're they're
they're Hit or
Miss yeah so it
depends and what what Braden do you do
you help uh mom look out for your your
brothers there that's very you're
becoming the man of the house now right
you're
13 mhm
I what was that was that was that Braden
making making a wisenheimer remark no it
was Gunner you saying he was about to be
something oh what what was that Gunner
I'm sorry you can speak too you don't
have to be
shy I'm about to be eight in March
you're
really you're about to be eight well
that's that's an important age do you
know why Eight's an important
age no birthday is coming well Mom will
tell you at eight that's when you get
all the best
chores yeah isn't that right
Katie yeah I got lots of them yeah well
the good news is you have a lot of you
have a lot of three boys there we used
to call them Farm hands so if they're
not pulling their weight then they they
can expect a lump of coal in their
stocking so all you boys are good and
listen to Mom and make sure that you're
helping her when she
asks y all right and Braden being the
man of the house now that falls uh on
you quite a bit uh these days which I
know is is sometimes difficult to do but
you're 13 what kind of things do you do
that to help
Mom um I uh do things that she normally
does like you have a bunch of animals
outside that need to be fed every night
and before she gets home I would feed
them she gets on do all that what kind
of animals you don't you don't have
reindeer there in Texas do you no we
have goats pigs um cows got we got cats
do we don't not have chickens no chicken
mom doesn't like chickens because I poop
every oh well I don't blame her we had
chickens here at the North Pole for a
while and they're just they're
ill-tempered goats goats are a little
easier to work with do now I see you
feed your reindeer candy canes no no I
don't feed the reindeer candy canes they
they have acid reflux with
that yeah so they typically eat know
they have they have a Salt Lick they
have oats and uh we have to sprinkle you
know of course on uh on Christmas Eve
they get a little something extra they
get a little bit of uh sometimes a
little bit of coffee because it's a long
night but reindeer are tough to take
care of they need to be out here in the
cold in the North Pole and they don't do
very well in that Texas heat so so
Braden do you feed all the animals
yourself or do your little brothers help
you all right well look that's important
because you know your mom has a lot to
do feeding all those animals that sounds
like a lot of work but she does have
three boys there three you all look like
big strong boys so helping out with that
helping out with cleaning around the
house and and most important you know
letting your mom know that you're there
for her that you love her do you do you
let your mom know often that you love
her yes ma totally
yes that didn't sound convincing I think
you're you're going to have to give Mom
a kiss in the cheek or give her a hug to
make Santa believes
you
hug okay that's nice come on everyone
get in there there's room to go around
Braden you're not too cool you're never
too old to hug Mom all right oh okay
well let's mom said that you've all been
very good and uh you know sometimes here
at the North Pole because we get busy we
can't do everything on Christmas Eve
some people if you've been very good in
particular you can get some gifts early
did you know that that sometimes Santa
does that
really that yes that's that's part of
the deal but really it's it's very
limited it's sort of a frequent flyer
mile for kids who've been who've been
good all year like Platinum Elite so we
have some gifts for you there uh right
now which I believe you can open the
first one you each have a gift that's
meant for each of you you have one for
Camden Braden and you have one for
gunner right there there you go you
you'll still be getting gifts on
Christmas but uh this is one that's
special for each of you go ahead and and
open it up your mom let us know that
this was something you all
enjoyed how do you open this how let's
get some Christmas cheer playing
[Music]
there you guys probably do it about
minut this
AIG that is
that's a big Lego and I tried to pick
the right one for each of you those
those are right up your alley right the
kind of Legos that you
like
yeah he got like Lego for Christmas no
not Christmas I mean his birthday so
he's kind of now getting a collection of
Legos okay so he's he's growing his
collection and Katie does he clean them
up after he plays with them where do we
put these no no no we we put them on
like like desk oh okay so so you put
them on
display all right well look and I know
Legos are fun and that's important
because you know it does actually help
left brain right brain when you're
building and it's it's good for you it
keeps you sharp but I also know that uh
you kids like to do more than just
Legos and so actually where where is he
going I can't see is that is that Gunner
he's walking
off okay again looking at a small screen
oh Camden come on stay with us here
brother you're going to miss the grand
finale cuz you got Legos and that's
that's
cool but we have one more gift for you
for all three of you that I know you
wanted and you can all use together so
we want to bring some Christmas cheer
there to your household your mom asked
for this specifically and you can open
it all right now as a gilray family
together I know get this
side
basketball we should give can no
no all of ours hold it's all of yours
it's it's
look it's all of yours to share now
wasn't that that was on your Christmas
list wasn't
it yes and you know that they're hard to
come by those right now they're they're
selling like hot
cakes that's a big one wow what the
newest one thank you this is the Xbox
right that's the newest one you and if
you're
good if you're good boys oh I just see a
hand coming in there it's like
thing I can't read go
ahead Bren Braden you can
read oh yeah I can read but curses a
little bit oh okay I thought you said I
can't read I was saying that's come on
now I read I can read a lot of those
games now they have more reading than
playing all right let's
open I think I have an idea what they
are I know what it is yeah yes
yes what was
that what is it tell everybody tell
Santa right there
that's that's that's a lot well you know
your mom wanted to make sure that you
all had a special Christmas and now keep
in mind you still have to be good all
the way up until an including
Christmas yep just to be sure and you
know what do you think that your oh is
that is that Camden again is that he
just keeps walk that's yeah that's what
is he walking off is there does he have
a Handler who is handing his gifts to
it's just the ottoman uh oh okay I tell
you I don't know if you're familiar with
the Ottoman Empire but they tried their
way up here and didn't work at that
period in time but it shaved years off
of St Nick's
life
now
cam cam didn't Gunner you're not just
GNA walk off now now that you have your
gifts are you I'm just holding tight on
this he do not there is more over there
well there is more over there but let me
ask you this if you're good boys do you
think that maybe your mom's been working
really hard and maybe your mom deserves
something special this year and I have
heard by the way well the first thing is
actually uh your mom Katie of course the
Gilroy family I know that uh you haven't
had a lot of time for yourself and so
right there I believe there's a gift
card for
you if they can hand it over there to
Katie to make sure that you can take
extra there you go let's hey look can
you give me a drum roll with with your
go no that's okay elf not right now not
right now uh for your mom this is
something for your mother so that she
can have some special time to herself
considering all the chaos that I'm
witnessing here right
nowan oh wow you can go by yourself and
I will gladly go by myself oh my God
thank you thank so much Katie and that
we we you know we thought about doing
that all right just maybe a few hours
but you you deserve yourself at least a
day or two to take care of yourself and
and Braden you're going to help take
care of your brothers while mom has some
time to herself can you do that
definitely I
can as long as it it
Tak I know there's more but look the
rest of this is actually going to Mom
you part of Christmas is being grateful
for the things we have like very large
heavy Xboxes
yeah so yes K Katie also as well uh
that's not all that we have for you
because I know that you've had a tough
spell uh here these last couple of years
and this is the time of year where
really there are special cases who we
want to help and so we'll hit this
Christmas cheer and bring in we have a
check right here for you Katie here at
the North Pole that will be delivered to
you Ed mcmah
style for
$10,000 right there to help the Gilroy
family this year in this I'm going to
hand this back to the elf because it's
heavy
just these are tears of joy correct it's
not like you expecting like another zero
on there that is unreal wow okay oh my
god well I tell you what your story
obviously has touched people here at the
North Pole and uh part of what we do we
really want to give back and we just ask
that whenever you can you help other
people in need you see them because we
can all help everyone even if we're in
need there are always some people who
could use little help sometimes they
have more sometimes they have less
sometimes they don't need toys or money
sometimes they just need a hug or
someone to listen to them and it sounds
like your mom has been there for a lot
of people helping them and listening to
them and so we do have one more gift for
you Mama Gilroy one more and I believe
right now they're going to I would like
for you right now Katie to go look
outside look outside we have a present
for you you open that up open that box
up first open the box up and then head
on
outside that's a hint what is it what is
it way well that's why you have to go
outside people oh my gosh there's more
to life than a
screen let's go outside Katie go outside
go go we'll we'll be able to see you out
there don't worry this way guys right
here this way and here she
comes and right out there oh my
gosh in the driveway for you
Katie because we know that you needed a
little bit of help getting to and fro
and we wanted to make sure you had
something that getting washed it's
already getting washed m oh Mommy
already getting lost well that's not the
main takeaway but straight
from we had some help from Glen pooke
Autoplex that's a 2023 Dodge Durango for
you and your family so you can take them
where they need to go and hopefully make
your day today a little easier there
Katie oh that's what I love to
see get in there
Camden thank you so much oh Katie thank
you for everything that you've done and
the family that you
have it's crazy thank you guys so
crazy it's not expecting me shaking I he
is
shaking oh my
gosh want to go get in don't be ugly and
wet I know right now you might get wet
well you know what you can go and check
it out afterward I assure you it's it's
it's real you know it's not like it's
just out there on cinder blocks with no
engine in
it so Katie I know that you're busy I
know you have a lot to do Katie Braden
gunar
Camden is it is it anything you'd like
to ask santa anything you'd like to say
any to anyone out there in in closing
this Christmas
thank you so much so much for everything
oh well I didn't mean to thank you I
didn't know maybe you had a question
about how things worked but you know I
guess people figure everything out now
with social media so there's no
curiosity Gap Katie we really hope that
this goes uh goes some ways with your
family to to making your years a little
easier and making being a mom to three
rambunctious but mostly good boys uh
that much that much more pleasant
and brings a little bit of joy to your
life thank you so much this is a huge
blessing oh well you've been a blessing
not only to Santa but to a lot of people
out there who I think will be very
inspired by your story and uh realize
that we all go through times and
sometimes are tough sometimes you get
tough breaks too but you know sometimes
you also see a little silver lining and
there are people out there who are
willing to help and sometimes that
person is you so I do this for a living
so sometimes you know I I get used to it
but it always brings a twinkle to my eye
and you can do the same for a neighbor
maybe there's a neighbor who needs help
needs a meal maybe there's someone who
doesn't have somewhere to go for
Christmas day go out there invite him
over just say here here's a turkey leg
whatever you have you can pay it
forward
will thank you so much and we'll follow
up with you and uh I'm sure you'll be
again you still have to be good all the
way through Christmas boys I'm sure
there's more coming down that chimney
but you have to stay on top of it and of
course mama will uh will let us know
isn't that right
Katie will yes thank you so much gilray
family we appreciate you writing in we
appreciate everything you do for your
mother for your community and I'll
certainly be seeing you soon Merry
Christmas Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas all right now
see you Christmas Eve bye G
family oh that was fun I love it I'm not
crying you're crying I'm totally
crying you I can't I can't cry because
then it runs into my beard and I look
like one of those white dogs always has
the streaks you know I love it for
Braden obviously he's carrying a very
heavy load but you can see kind of the
joy that you knew his mom got to field
he really seems to care about his mom
you know the other two they might be
young or they could find themselves on
the naughty list they keep running off
like that but the good news is there's
plenty of space to run back and forth in
that have you been inside of that no
it's it's it's the SXT too it's very
nice right that that's the extended
edition yeah it's fantastic and you know
I mean not everyone can have a sleigh so
sometimes you settle for a Dodge Durango
but they seem happy with
it and so as we uh continue on here
today actually I believe it's time for
another yes well some some people here
to the program who we more greetings
some more Christmas greetings sometimes
they say holiday greetings but Santa
doesn't play holiday greetings we don't
do Quan up here in the North Pole let's
go see some more friends for some
Christmas
greetings I just wanted to take a moment
to thank all the folks out there who
have signed up for mug Club I want to
wish all the great Patriots at mug Club
an amazing Christmas God bless you all
my fondest memory of me and St first
time we met he was doing a gig up the
street I was doing a gig at another club
I go to see him I was done early I hit
him in the chest with full H and he
comes off the stage ready to fight
realize I'm his favorite comic of all
time we go out get drunk we're in the
hotel room they put us up the same Hotel
different Club I said I'm going to get a
pizza I get on the phone I call a hooker
hooker shows up half all Steven's drunk
panics kills the guy so what do we do so
we have to cut him up in the tub luckily
lint in had a pool but it was cold out
had the cover on it we threw the chunks
under the pool that's my fondest memory
of me and
[Applause]
[Music]
St for you right now Katie to go look
outside come on boys we need your help I
can't
open that box first
open oh my God what is it what is
it oh my
gosh oh my
gosh a
cold I'm going to go get those you ready
C all right get the hoodie
up let's go can we get
shotgun I am I have Missy feet my feet
this is look it's the third row oh my
gosh oh my gosh this is so cool you can
spit like four people like this is
actually amazing there there's two more
you sp this is actually amazing spit
like seven people in here mommy there's
two more seats in the
back
start
wrong God is good God is good God is
good do that but there's some more
presents for the boys what do you think
is that okay if we open a few more oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah cam we're going to
open some more presents if you want
let's go
Bud open open yeah open them open them
at the same time that's
great yeah Christmas
colors yes I got a m oh there's a
headset
y thank you Merry Christmas to you
tooing that was a good
one okay all indoor indoor
[Applause]
[Music]
play
I'm not crying you're crying no I think
all of us were at some point during that
not me
yes held back
tears
professional s
Nick all right all right all right oh
there you go there we go all right and
actually uh it's time to you know this
is something that uh bring a smile to
your face those were tears of joy of
course yeah from you well and not Chris
kingle not okay not Chris cringle I love
but I don't cry you know tears freeze in
the North Pole practical ex it's like
Cold Stone crey in your under eyes
yeah so we've been
working are they still around cold Sten
creamy oh I hope not oh well you know
you know where they got that North Pole
yep it was an accident another it was an
accident we just dropped some ice cream
out and then we had some we had some of
the leftover candy can need to go scoop
it up bundled it together just slapped
it and they said hey let's build a
franchise can't believe it and we never
got any royalties spy satellites oh
don't get me started on dipp and dots I
know so we've told you that we've been
working with the One Tribe Foundation
founded actually this foundation in 2013
and you know what actually here to to
tell you better than I could ever
explain it are the founders of the feast
I believe we have them on the line let's
go you know Santa's more used to
traveling around and days and reindeer
but I tell you what get me in front of a
screen and S doing all these te
technological calls I think it's the
blue light yeah it's tough apparently it
interferes with your Cadian Rhythm all
right I see right there if I'm not
mistaken we have the founders of the One
Tribe Foundation is that Jacob shik and
we have senior director Don
win that's correct Santa on Santa oh
thank you so much for making the time
and two good looking chaps there too oh
I thought Santa didn't tell a lie no
well listen it's a little thing you know
what you have to ask yourself what's
better a lie that draws a smile or a
tear that draws a truth truth that draws
a tear I was confused by wind's
mullet wi can you turn around and show
everyone that this is what is don't be
jealous you like that don't you oh okay
I'm not it's a it's a it's a baby man
bun it's a baby man bun and this is of
your own valtion correct that's correct
I did not lose a bet well I can't you
gota you gotta forgive him Santa he was
motor te in the Marine Corps okay I see
there's a little and and and uh Jacob
what were you I was the 0331 machine
gunner in the okay all right and when
you're gonna let him talk to you like
that around Christmas yes he absolutely
is you know it's very similar to the
camaraderie we have here on the North
Pole with the elves and uh boy we're
sure glad that they're not recording
everything because hey it's in good fun
it's in good fun last thing we need is
people getting cancelled for a good
North Pole joke uh well I don't know uh
how much I we've been talking with
everyone today the families who you sent
over and uh we've been able to help a
lot of them it was very touching we
wouldn't have been able to do it without
your help and locating and and and
vetting the right families can you tell
everyone watching right now what it is
that that you do and how you created The
One Tribe
Foundation sure 10 years ago we started
a push-up campaign and it was known as a
22 push-up 22 kill push-up Challenge and
it didn't go viral until uh 2016 because
nothing happens overnight and it didn't
go viral until the rock did it so we're
grateful to the Rock good dude but we
wanted to raise awareness of suicide
epidemic that was plaguing our warrior
class and when all the support started
pouring in because we didn't set it up
as a fundraiser we didn't know what to
do with those funds and so we ended up
being a pass through entity for several
other nonprofits that we knew and are
partnered with to do good work until we
decided if we're really going to change
these men and women's lives we got to
get our hands on them and keep them on
them and so that's when we started to
develop in-house programming and then a
couple years ago we did a name
transition from 22 kill to one trap
Foundation meaning the human trap we all
we bleed red we're all connected by
default and so since the 22 kill push-up
days we've evolved into a full-blown
mental and emotional Wellness entity
that provides support and services to
military veterans First Responders Law
Enforcement Officers Frontline
healthcare workers and their families
and so we're uh very grateful to do the
work we do and it comes from a very
honest Place considering our backgrounds
and we just want people to know that
worthy of being loved and
uh that it's okay to not be okay right
and I know that you do a lot your very
handson and of course you you do a lot
of things financially and pragmatically
but sometimes really it's just it's like
little boys and girls around at
Christmas it's just important sometimes
that they know someone's thinking of
them absolutely exactly that's exactly
what what uh at the heart of it uh what
the one tribe is about is forming that
human tribe
creating that community and uh being
around like-minded individuals well
that's great and I know that uh with you
everything really a lot goes directly to
the families and need and you know we
spend a lot of time here at the North
Pole we do a lot of work through
Charities but uh you know not not all of
them are created equal uh for example
there's the One Foundation at one point
less than 1% ironically went to those
who needed help and so we really always
want to look for the people where
they're going to put the resources to
the place where they do the most good
and I want everyone out there to know
how Hands-On you guys really are and
passionate because that's not always the
case and it really touched us all here
at the North
Pole we really appreciate that I mean we
really do because um this job is
definitely not for the faint of heart
it's something that will test your grit
and test your will and um we're very
grateful to God that we're still here
and still doing this work uh that we
believe is definitely needed and
it's a higher calling it really is
because we know we're never going to bat
a thousand there's some people that we
work with and we pour into and we have
to bury them and uh we know that and we
love them all the way anyway and so we
appreciate you saying that because
that's important to us we appreciate
what you do every every bit as much as
the actual fighting that you've done for
this country which you know we know all
too well out here and sometimes it's lip
service we appreciate that you've done
that but also the fight that a lot of
people forget about when these people
come home sometimes uh wartime Heroes
Have a tough time during peace sometimes
it's harder for them once they get out
of the war and it becomes a war in
themselves and they get tossed by the
wayside so we really very much
appreciate it before we have one last
thing for you because we've talked with
these families who you sent to us uh
this week let everyone know out there
who's watching from the North Pole and
across across the whole world where
International now thanks to technology
where people can go to support you and
look into what you do a little more
absolutely just go to onbe
foundation.org the number one onri
foundation.org come visit us to see what
we do uh you can definitely log in and
and uh see see how much how you can
contribute to to this uh organization
and see all the good that we're doing
here and you can and can you can provide
merchandise because we're coming up on
Christmas that helps with our overhead
and your very own Don wi created all of
it
oh that's that's well well there you go
we do actually we I believe that a lot
of merchandise just got sent to a to a
homeless shelter but I think we've had
some returns from skidrow and
so there will be plenty you know look
you can't make you can't make everyone
happy sometimes even if it's free so
we'll do and that's one thing do I like
that when you do people out there good
though homeless people are gonna be
looking good it's our stuff that's that
was what we thought but not everyone
agrees but hey that's the beauty of you
know America it's you know a difference
of opin North Pole is really it's not
exactly the same thing it's kind of a
Puerto Rico situation but I won't bore
you with the details one thing too I
think some people out there they see
what we've done here today and think oh
I I don't have those kinds of Financial
Resources but there are ways that people
can help with you just things that they
have or their time or their skill set
right I think a lot of people they don't
realize that's just as important and
it's needed just as much absolute fact
absolutely you do not have to wear a
uniform in order to serve your nation
it's a misnomer
you wake up and be giving it's a season
of giving be willing to give your time
just like you said Sant be willing to
give your talent and volunteer and come
help out we me we can't have enough
advocates for volunteers the more the
better over here we say you know this
the whole Foundation this whole
organization started because a couple of
Marines gave a them and that that's all
we're asking is for people to give a
them and obviously Santa you give a dam
and we appreciate that yes thank we
really do and you know what I can't take
all the credit the the elves also do too
A lot of people don't know that these
elves are uh they're all
volunteers that's actually what they're
here not because they have to but
because they want to there was a spell
back in around the 1800s where few of
them tried to unionize and you know we
had to have
a we had to let you know look you set
them straight you I appreciate it s you
set them straight no no no no no the the
the North Pole is a it's a it's a right
to work again not exactly state but you
know it's a Puerto Rico situation so
well the other elves decided no we think
we have a pretty good deal and it's
things are Lost in Translation you know
I was around before the term indentured
servitude was even a thing so you know
we have to switch with the times but the
elves seem to be happy with it now we do
have one more thing here today we've
helped the families directly but we also
wanted to do a little bit more and help
your organization as you go into the new
year so one final surprise here for the
One Tribe Foundation we have the elf
bringing it in this is for you Jacob and
Don it's heavy is another check directly
for you to do the good that you continue
to do for
10,000 and that's an American currency
not North
Pole we are very grateful and humble
thank you so much Santa because every
penny is going to be used to continue
the fight for the greater good and we we
truly appreciate you guys thank you so
much Santa boys and girls Santa does
exist and he's awesome all right thank
you so much and and we'll be sending by
the way uh
some more there uh behind the scenes and
and some more resources so we'll be in
touch I'll have some Elves reach out to
you and and help you with things that
you need we really appreciate all the
good that you do all the good that
you've done and uh we're very grateful
to be a part of it thank you
genuinely thank you s God bless
absolutely Merry Christmas go have a
good time with your man
bun I don't fully understand it but
that's a oh
look at this oh oh he's losing his
antlers oh oh oh oh that's Joe Lewis
there at the North Pole I don't know if
you know this but that's actually that's
actually years of evolution camouflage
really yes stark white just fits right
in but it's but the fact that he
actually has no cold tolerance is one of
Nature's
cruestv tail do you hear that working
against the North Pole well in being an
Al it's at the wrong height it's at the
wrong height you yes it's a tail that's
a whip and boy sometimes he'll clear a
table and Santa you know it's actually a
good thing that I have this belly that
hangs a little bit low which sort of
acts like some protection Joe Lewis we
can let let's let him go back out to the
toy shop he doesn't he doesn't want the
reindeer he doesn't want those
antlers and I don't blame him it's
understandable the reindeer don't want
the reindeers they don't no by the way
it's in the way did you know that
reindeer they're very different to hunt
than moose really moose get aggressive
reindeers
freeze they're peaceful animals you know
well they they pull the sleigh Santa so
you know we didn't really have to they
pull the sleigh that's true but there
might be a little bit of chemical
enhancement that's Christmas
magic it's acceptable it's acceptable oh
you try going around the whole world in
one night by the way just can I clarify
one thing because I know some people
people out there I get it your doubters
and you don't want to you don't want to
do the math look Santa doesn't have to
go around the entire world in one night
okay so for the children watching look
it's a simple mathematical equation
first off not everyone celebrates
Christmas which I think is sad but very
sad yes you know it's 2023 they have the
right to not everyone celebrates
Christmas not everyone as a child Santa
brings Christmas gifts to children not
to everybody so now we've reduced that
by a significant amount and there is
something known as well the Naughty Nice
List that's a calling every year it does
yes and it grows it grows year by year
so everyone out there look you're making
Santa's job easier ironically also have
you heard of time zones it's a great
convention isn't it it's it's one of
those things people don't take into
account just there are a lot of people
who and not to mention how many people
do you actually know out there who truly
keep the spirit of Christmas alive and
believe in Santa Claus that number is
far lower than you would think and so
it's not and also there is a little bit
of Christmas magic where it's sort of a
time slip there's a way to slow it down
you kind of buried the lead there Santa
That's yes but the important thing is
the the pragmatic approach is time zones
not everyone celebrates Christmas the
naughty list adults lots of doubters
that right there narrows it down and
then yeah I also have the ability to
slow down
time that seems like a really good thing
to be able to do so cool it does that's
cool so Co the problem is when you slow
down time you age at an accelerated rate
is that why yes I was fully gray I mean
Santa you by the time I was 112 you look
great for your age because I know you're
very old but I'm telling you I did not
have we had one Christmas that year you
know there was the there was the year
the shot Hood around the world are you
familiar with f Ferdinand yes yes I
wasn't gray before then really just
happened wow lot of stress lot of stress
lot of stress eating and you know what
the point is hey look be kind to
yourselves be kind to those people
around you of course you need to be
disciplined and make sure that you're
doing the right thing but hey every now
and then we have a misstep and every now
and then someone out there maybe needs a
little bit of help and you're there
every how many times have you in your
life I think everyone here needed needed
a hand up well not there's a difference
between a leg up and a hand out right
especially for people out there who've
dedicated their lives to helping serving
other people and sometimes it presents
in different ways sometimes it's someone
who's served their country living
through Horrors that many of us can only
imagine sometimes it's as simple as a
young boy performing the heick that he
learned on a YouTube short right saving
someone else's life and sometimes it can
be as simple as helping Mom after a long
day do the dishes if Dad isn't around
anymore and you have to be the man of
the house but really Christmas of course
everyone says it's about giving
presents as much as it is receiving
presents but that's also a Miss for a
long time people weren't giving out
presents there as a long period people
were happy to get an orange it was
exotic was before modern
shipping Refrigeration there a period of
time people if they had they had a
fillet of trout I had to sandwich it in
a barrel through layers of
salt wasn't easy we didn't have to
always make toys you're right we we
switched over from The Agrarian gifts
it's true and then got into the toy
making the point is everything tasted
the same but guess what people were
happy for the little bit that they did
have Santa started out just helping in a
way that we saw need North Pole and we
weren't in the same kind of need and we
said okay what can we do here this year
and those grew and our operations became
more efficient and no one's as grateful
as I am but sometimes I wish we could go
back to a simpler time where we're not
only grateful for the things that we had
but helped each other in the community
and looked around to see who else out
there needed a little bit of help that's
really what this is about on a
day-to-day basis at Christmas there are
people right now who need help in your
neighborhood maybe on your block in your
city they could be public servants they
could be veterans they could be moms
without a dad they could be dads without
a moms they could be people who are sick
they could be children who are
struggling at school and there's
something that you can do to help them
there's always something that you can do
to help the person next to you just
think about what that is be
mindful and you know I will say this
that's what Santa is it's sort of a
parable that everyone can understand
giving to people while expecting nothing
in return but it's important that I tell
you
Christmas and that's why we don't do
holidays Christmas there was a great one
who came before me who did a lot more
than just deliver some
presents was someone who delivered
himself if you know what I'm talking
about you know
how serious that was how dark this world
was for a period of time and hope was
given to everyone whether you choose to
accept it or not the world changed from
one way of Darkness
hopelessness lost
soullessness just to the change of
having a
choice and having hope it was so
significant that we changed our calendar
for it we have the world was one way and
it changed after this date which we
celebrate as Christmas day to be another
way so whether it's oranges trout
sandwiched through layers of salt before
Refrigeration or
oranges that came back into fashion you
know yeah they did have it com back or
Xboxes it's but a drop in the bucket
from what came before all of us here and
what we have done today is but a drop in
the bucket that uh compared to
everything you've done out there we we
support you we appreciate
you it really is mutual support so thank
you everything that youve done for us
and making this possible to mug Club I
have to take off my gloves because I get
a little
clammy and we do this every year it's
one of little Joys that we get to do
that really it's kind of selfish we get
to enjoy this and you get to see
hopefully the fruits of your
contributions your labor we appreciate
it we wish you all a very Merry
Christmas a happy New Year and mug Club
we will see you and all the new members
who joined over
Christmas in January 2024 Merry
Christmas
come to M Club we'll get together have a
few
laughs jail gives the worst
directions
okay all right
okay there's an escape back there join
mug club today for $89 annually to
support content like this and get access
to the entire network
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub
[Music]
where the white women
at
[Music]
[Applause]
you're a strange animal that's what I
know I know what I know
[Music]
stral